speaking of defendants stephen bannon is
expected today to surrender and be
indicted
again
over the cash for the border wall scam
that he participated in this is very
interesting cnn reporting steve bannon
is expected to surrender today
to face new york state charges related
to his fundraising effort to build a
wall along the southern u.s border
remember this was the scam in which when
it became clear trump wasn't going to
build the wall and mexico wasn't going
to pay for it etc etc
um
some individuals including bannon
participated in a give us cash and will
build the wall thing and it was a total
scam
the state charges which have been
returned in an indictment are based on
the same conduct bannon was charged with
by federal prosecutors in 2020. if this
rings a bell it's because indeed bannon
was already charged federally for this
then president donald trump pardoned
bannon on those charges as he was
leaving office presidential pardons do
not apply to state investigations
robert costello an attorney for bannon
said wednesday that the former trump
aide is expected to plead not guilty
when he is arraigned the washington port
post first reported bannon's plans to
surrender
um
and then the other stuff i mean you got
you guys probably would uh understand or
expect all the other stuff bannon calls
the charges phony he says it's partisan
he says it's political weaponization he
says he's a leading voice to protect our
borders he says in fact i have not yet
begun to fight they will have to kill me
first which are certainly fighting words
there are two sides to this and i want
to remind you about the two and by by
the way by two sides i don't mean
there's two sides as to whether what
bannon did was wrong that's not what i
mean there's two aspects to this first
of all
does the evidence point to bannon
participating in a fraud it does that's
why he was indicted um federally and
that's why he is now being indicted at
the state level it is correct the
evidence points to it he should not
receive special treatment if the
evidence is there you must indict and
that's what's happening
the second part of this is
the victims of the fraud
the victims of the scam and we've talked
about this before remember that to make
an analogy after the 2020 election
when joe biden won and was clearly going
to become the president no matter what
donald trump tried to do
uh donald trump
started fundraising on send me money and
i will do audits and i will do recounts
and i will do legal challenges and of
course i knew and many of you knew those
were going nowhere and if you look at
the fine print a bunch of that money was
being used by trump to pay off campaign
debt and there was this rich guy who
donated i think it was like 250 000
maybe it was even more who then sued and
said i got scammed i should get my money
back because i got scammed by trump and
we said at the time
republicans constantly talk about buyer
beware and you can't have a nanny state
protecting everybody from everything so
should this guy really be allowed to sue
in this way now of course he's allowed
but it could be dismissed or whatever
found against him
there's a similar aspect here
in the same way that fox news argues
no one should seriously consider the
things tucker says to be literally true
he's doing entertainment you could make
the case that no one should really have
believed that steve bannon was going to
help fundraise for a privately funded
and privately built wall with mexico
it's absurd it doesn't make any sense
you'd have to be a [ __ ] to fall for
that
and so as a result of that
what what sort of protection what sort
of relief from the state
should the people that were scammed get
i don't believe that just because you're
a republican you deserve to be scammed i
don't believe that but there's a real
question about this is so absurd
that does it really warrant
relief for the people that were scammed
and if so what would that relief be i
don't know the answer but i want to hear
from you we'll have more on this and all
of our other stories from today on the
david pakman show instagram yes you can
find our instagram at davidpakmanshow
and you can also find some really wacky
hate mail i've gotten in the last few
days
on my instagram i am david.pakman
on instagram that's a period not like
spelling out dot
david dot pakman find me there
one of our sponsors is helix sleep i
have been sleeping on a helix mattress
for years and i always recommend it to
friends you'd simply take this helix
sleep quiz it asks you about your body
type your sleep position whether you
have back pain and then helix will match
you up with the mattress that is
personalized to your needs and they ship
it to you for free another reason i went
with helix is that unlike a lot of
mattress companies out there every
single helix mattress is made in the usa
by a skilled production team which means
when you buy a helix mattress you are
supporting great jobs i'm not the only
one who loves helix helix was recently
awarded number one mattress by both gq
and wired magazine every helix mattress
comes with a 10 or 15 year warranty you
can try it a hundred nights and send it
back for a full refund if you need to
support the david pakman show by getting
your next mattress from helix sleep and
you'll get up to 350 off any mattress
plus two free pillows when you go to
helix sleep.com pacman the link is down
below